if you've caught any news about the
border crisis in the last 24 hours you
have been subjected to a disgusting and
blatant attempt at emotional
manipulation now at a time when we
actually need something called real
reporting instead we get this but look
at the photos see for yourself that
group includes men women and several
children some of them trying to cross
after being denied access to the port of
entry where they could legally claim
asylum one photo shows a mother
struggling to scoop up her children and
flee the fumes from in this photo shared
around the world shows a family running
from the fumes that's it it's the one
photo on Sunday and a brazen act of
lawlessness scores of migrants attempted
to rush the border and they placed our
agents our sovereignty in peril border
patrol had two choices
let them overrun the US border like what
they did to Mexico's or Guatemala's or
use non-lethal tear gas to repel the
crowd now these are the only images the
media are circulating women and children
who appear to be running for their lives
the hyperbole the meter in the hyperbole
wasn't filled full tilt mode this is a
shameful American moment it's a shameful
American moment those children those
pictures are the pictures we saw at the
end of the Vietnam War now no one wants
to see children and distress but that
comment was an embarrassment and
remember Donald Trump didn't create this
crisis his foremost responsibility is
safeguarding the nation which is what
he's doing reporters who are either lazy
or agenda-driven are using their own
toxic agents to blur the eyes of the
public on this critical issue now this
is what really happened on Sunday the
way these people rushed the border was
absolutely monstrous they pushed women
and children up front and then behind
those women and children they started
throwing rocks cement bricks they
started throwing Bob
at our Border Patrol agents just a bunch
of modern-day patriots and as for the
mothers and children well did they make
up the bulk of those arrested no here's
our San Diego border chief Rodney Scott
we ended up making about 42 arrests only
eight of those were females and there
were only a few children involved the
vast majority of the people were dealing
with their adult males similar to what
we saw the first wave of the caravan
that came up about a week or so ago now
in total now about 69 arrests have been
made and the crisis continues to
escalate which the angle repeatedly
warned you would happen a new migrant
caravan from Central America the second
six months is now headed up through
Mexico to the United States this week
crusading reporters are feeding the
narrative that anyone opposed welcoming
these caravanners into our country are
cruel horrible awful rotten people these
caravans it's got to stop I mean it's
it's just it's just it's untenable it's
unsustainable the people in this country
want orderly immigration well of course
the atom splitter is over at the other
networks claimed it was no big deal
there is no invasion there is no
emergency they're panicked about this
make invasion for everybody out there
that was telling me no it's a real story
we're worried about the kids and they're
coming and true I'm strong enough to I'd
go back to what I said about Martians
coming in my backyard well they're not
coming he tried the caravans not coming
the leprosy is not coming I thought it's
not coming it's not just the media Know
Nothings though who need to be exposed
here we're making a list and we're
checking it twice
and others have been very naughty as
well on this issue now one of the prime
drivers of these never-ending care grant
caravans are groups such as Pueblo
sinfronteras and the Chicago braced
centro scene Fronteras they've been
organizing this caravan and other
caravans for months in fact years and
pueblos sinfronteras even put out a
press release this was last March that
reads like a you know some type of
primer for a borderless world this is my
favorite line in the press release
we demand of Mexico in the United States
that they open the borders to the US
because we're as much citizens as the
people of the countries where we are
and/or travel what okay they're not
American citizens but this is a classic
citizens of the world claptrap that's
been funded by billionaires who want
transmigration to be a universal right
now number two on our naughty list
activist judges acting like a super
legislature district court judges
continue to frustrate the president's
every initiative when it comes to
immigration enforcement just last week
the president was hit with two
devastating rulings in the first case
Judge John s Teague R and Obama
appointee from the Ninth Circuit natch
barred the president from limiting a
silent asylum claims to those who enter
the country legally that in Michigan
judge mark Goldsmith ordered the release
of nearly one hundred Iraqis who were
incarcerated under the trump travel ban
now all of this explains why the
president is running very short on
patience to shame it's a shame to
disgrace frankly some judge sitting in
some location very far away is telling
our incredible military and law
enforcement what to do and it's not
right and it's been going on like that
for a long time this nationwide
junctions have got to be stopped
now he's absolutely right certain judges
have completely abandoned their article
three limits and are totally out of
control but Congress perhaps more than
all of the other culprits on this
naughty list deserves the most of the
blame here now both parties could have
solved this nightmare had they acted to
shore up the asylum loopholes while
Obama was still president Democrats
should have struck a deal also with
Trump while the iron was hot last
January Republicans were willing to
grant a pathway to citizenship for
nearly two million illegals fixing the
daca problem they want he'll do this for
a limit on chain migration and Visa
Lottery and of course the funding for
his board
now Trump was actually excited about the
prospect of this deal I will consider
that a great achievement to solve the
daka problem it's been out there for a
long time these are good people these
are people that should be able to stay
in this country now it didn't matter
Schumer rejected this out of hand it was
more important in the end for the
Democrats to deny Trump a win on
immigration than it was for the
Democrats to agree to protect our
country and even avoid the type of
crisis we see on the border now now at
the same time many weak-kneed
Republicans many of whom are captive to
agribusiness or the hospitality or
construction industries were unwilling
to go to the map for the Trump agenda so
nothing ended up getting done with 12
legislative days left until they lose
power in the house and only 15 in the
Senate Republicans must unite and make
passing Trump's immigration enforcement
agenda a priority working through
Christmas and shutting down the
government yes if that's necessary this
is a crisis that must be addressed
immediately and we know that once Nancy
has the gavel back the Democrats answer
to scenes like this will be to just
simply allow the situation to worsen
encouraging thousands more to storm our
borders and put women and children at
risk the Republicans meanwhile have a
chance to make this short session of
Congress a lot less lame by addressing
the most immediate problem facing our
country today but I am Telling You if
the Republicans duck it once again they
shouldn't expect to be back in charge
anytime soon and that's the angle